- It's a mindset game, Iris.
- [Iris] It is.
(mellow groovy music)
- Okay.
(clattering)
- Did you go?
- How's it going, dude?
- Good, man.
- I think probably similar to you guys.
Just thinking about what
aspects we wanna build out now.
- [Gary] 100%.
- And it's what--
- I would argue the biggest thing
you guys should be thinking about
is tripling down on how you got here.
Something I've been thinking
about you, your bro,
and other, like the top 10,
is everybody's now in a mad dash
to monetize, as they should,
these are remarkably big numbers.
I just don't think you're going away.
And if you're not going away.
My big thing now, more than ever,
is how do you go way more
back to the consumer.
I think, if I heard today
that you're doing a two hour
Q&A live stream every
single day with your fans,
like Juice with Jake and it's like,
you're literally just drinking
apple juice in the morning,
a different juice every morning.
And just two hours like real, real.
Not even on an entertainment kick.
Just like fucking GMA even.
Maybe it's weird that I'm bringing this up
when you just went on
the old version of it
and just like, "How are you doing?
"Cool.
"Sarah, thank you for that.
"Yeah I do remember..."
Like, just real.
As if you were with 20
kids that have loved you,
oh shit I forgot about that fucking post
or like what has happened to SallyPants49,
she did have three million,
hope she's doing well.
To me what I'm feeling right now,
is this is the moment more than ever
to unmonetize and
quadruple down on audience.
While it's under-priced.
While it's under-priced attention,
get as much as you can,
because the monetizing
can be done at any point.
And I just think everyone's like, again,
having empathy, when you're
young, you're on the ride,
there's a level, the insecurities change.
Insecurities drive so much.
The insecurity now is
can I be a professional
and build an empire and
be a business man or woman
ad that level, you know what I mean?
It's fun to watch.
So I think it's a very special,
interesting time for you,
where that's just one thing
I would give a lot of thought to.
I really would.
- I agree.
- Like I don't know, honestly
I'm giving myself advice
as I'm talking to you.
This is always the religion.
And it's an interesting time.
Because you become the next,
you become the next Brad Pitt.
This is how it happens.
Like if you're 13 right now,
you're the establishment.
And that new person that
popped last week is you.
It's just you wake up and it is.
It's funny to think though.
- I think we're gonna
see in the next year that
the gaming space is gonna--
- [Gary] Dude, we've been on
it forever, like we've put--
- Heavy like lifestyle, it's
gonna move more into like--
- You saw what happened last night.
Last night was the moment it changed.
I mean we're putting
together a video right now,
I'm glad to see you're not doing it,
that means Batman's
making a good one, right?
Iris?
(mumbling)
Seth, alright.
- [Jake] What's it about?
It just all, this is what's
great about filming yourself.
It's fucking me in 2014, 15,
16, 17 talking about Twitch.
And then I made, I literally
landed at 4:30 this morning,
I'm like, alright it happened last night,
the crossover moment.
Here comes people that ask
me what I think abut it,
here's what I think abut it.
This is what I think of this.
(video game digital music)
That's what I trade on, right?
Like that's what's good
about how I do what I do.
Like the world is your fucking oyster.
My big thing right now is
when you're king of the hill,
triple down on it.
(mumbling)
More.
I would go back to Jake Paul 0.1
where it was just about the audience.
Like as much as you can.
And I know you can't go
all the way back, I get it.
I get it.
But if I can get you 70% back of that 30%
of what you're actually doing now,
your whole world will be different.
Audiences know.
Just so you know.
They will never be tricked.
Either you're doing it for them
or you're doing it for yourself.
When you audit your
fucking last three weeks
and you think about how
many hours you spent on
what's for you, what's for them,
it doesn't look pretty
and it doesn't look pretty
for any of the A lists
right now in our world.
So cool.
And it's driven by the
right thing, I get it.
You did that first, you're
trying to make your name
in the next thing, I get it.
But I'm telling you that's
where the secret is.
(clapping)
- Appreciate it.
- Good to see you.
(clapping)
- Keep doing it.
- I will, my man.
He guys, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
This is the fifth of pod sessions.
- May name is Arabella S. Ruby.
And I am an actress and
a CEO of my own company.
- Great to be here.
My name is Rich Roll.
I am a recovering attorney
turned ultra endurance athlete.
- Gabriel Anderson.
I actually run our VaynerBeta business,
which is our small mid-market business.
Been working alongside Gary
for five and a half almost six years.
- It's like, who are you?
Who the fuck are you?
And if you can't answer that
question honestly for yourself,
you can pick a goal, you
can be motivated by Gary
and take advantage of the tools
that he puts out in the world,
but you might be climbing a ladder that's
leaning up against the wrong wall.
So you really need to take
the time to step back.
- [Gary] Taste, taste, taste.
- And really get to know who you are.
Like what is your unique design?
- [Gary] Taste, I call it taste.
- And what is it that gets
you outta bed and excited
and if you can be super honest about that,
and crack the veneer of denial
and all these things that hold you back,
that is the path forward.
But if you wanna just leapfrog over that,
because you think that's an inconvenience.
- [Gary] You're finished.
- You can go, yeah, you can
chase stuff your whole life,
but you're never gonna be a
fully integrated authentic person,
and you're never gonna
achieve your potential.
- [Gary] It's the process.
- And you're never gonna
be able to share what it is
that is most valuable not just to yourself
but to whoever happens
to be paying attention
to whatever you're doing.
- Where's Samir?
There he is.
What's happening?
(mumbling)
No not generally,
like what's happening
right now with the ad?
(mumbling)
Not like what's happening in life.
I wanna hack,
Only think I care about
is under-priced attention.
(mumbling)
Under-priced attention.
That's all I give a fuck about.
Like you need to play 10 cents at a time,
a dollar, five dollars, thousand dollars,
I don't care what it is.
Under-priced attention.
That's my religion.
- Your Russia video...
(mumbling)
(rustling)
(laughing)
- Won the chip, touring this morning.
- What?
(mumbling)
Is today Thursday?
- Yeah.
- Holy shit is,
did it start?
- [Man] Yeah.
- I didn't fix my bracket.
Fuck.
I know I felt good about.
But not great.
(laughing)
(mumbling)
- [Man] We had a big fucking twenty.
- What's happening, what's the scores?
Can somebody please put,
Dio, could you put up a game there?
Thank you.
How quickly can we move?
- [Man] Uh, however--
- What happened, what happened?
What happened?
(mumbling)
What?
(crowd mumbling)
Loyola did what?
Against who?
- Miami, beat Miami.
- [Gary] Loyola beat Miami?
- They're going to Chicago.
- [Gary] Somebody's losing their money.
Go get this Cyrus, go find
the person the happiest.
Somebody won, go find them now.
(upbeat music)
- I think the more interesting thing
is that when somebody comes
that it's exciting.
This is where my team sits.
There's like, this is my favorite row.
That's literally my favorite part
of my entire company set up.
But I'm gonna ruin it and
set up something right here,
just gonna try and give you some context.
Right?
This is the side wall,
it's where you come in.
Actually I'm gonna take you
right from the entrance of the
organization.
Alright.
So I'll just give you context, right.
So walking here, there's
my office over there.
So right here I wanna set up
some sort of Twitch set up.
This being, I mean to me,
again I'm gonna give you some context,
because I know when I
do these kinda things
sometimes it's hard, so here they are.
So to me it's kind of like,
somewhere here against this wall
is where I wanna put the,
I mean this seems to be the right place,
but am I thinking about it wrong?
I don't know.
You keep talking about it while
I just think for a second.
- That's just--
- I wanna take out all these desks.
This whole area and just
put tables for days.
We could just fit so many,
anyway, what else can I answer?
I'm building a Twitch studio right here,
I'm gonna play people on
old school video games.
- [Man] Oh, old school?
- And new school, I'll let you guys do it,
but I'm literally--
(mumbling)
You'll never beat me in Double Dribble.
(laughing)
(mumbling)
We'll see.
- Okay.
- We'll see.
We'll see.
You know what the good news is?
I can't wait to make the piece of content
where I beat your ass
and then I use this part
of the setup, because I already did that
with the Bubble Hockey.
The dude fucking flew in here
to take a fucking beating.
- From downtime (mumbling).
- We'll see, we'll see.
(laughing)
(light music)
It's a mindset game, Iris.
- [Iris] It is.
- Man, accountability.
- [Iris] About that?
- I'm just so about it right now.
So many of the emails I'm
getting and DMs and everything
are just 100% about once you understand
that you're accountable and
it's your fault for everything,
you become empowered because you realize
nobody's stopping you.
Not your parents, not the government,
not your circumstances.
When you take full accountability
and it's your fault,
it's fucking amazing.
- [Iris] Then you're in control.
- Then you're in control.
And that's what really
hurts people's feelings.
When you feel helpless
that you're not in control.
You know?
Should I just tweet
what's your phone number
and call people?
- [Iris] Yeah, that'd be fun.
(phone ringing)
- [Nick] Hello, is this Gary Vaynerchuk?
- It is, Nick.
How are you?
- [Nick] I'm doing excellent.
Thanks for calling.
- No problem, man.
What's been going on?
- [Nick] So I have my business,
my work, and then I'm just
super, super, super into music.
And so I see you and my boy doing
all the stuff that you guys are doing.
And I help actually
producers, music producers,
build Spotify playlists.
- Okay.
- [Nick] To help build their brand
and their social marketing.
- Smart, yep.
- Doesn't really make any money,
but it's something that I
still to create a network
sort of with producers
for other platforms.
- Yep.
- [Nick] I really, really enjoy it.
It doesn't feel like work.
And so it seems like I should put
a ton of energy into that.
But I'm also trying to build a business
where I don't have to do my full time job,
I can have this other stuff,
which I'm also passionate about,
but not nearly as passionate as--
- Dude, honestly this is so cliche
where people are trying to figure out
their time management
and their allocation.
I think people are mistaken
judging themselves when
they're doing things
that aren't clearly monetizable
because sometimes they become monetizable.
Like when I hear your story right now,
if somebody said bet
the farm, what happens.
I think you've got a business
in the music business
four years from now.
It's just gonna take four
years instead of 18 months,
because you're spreading
across three things,
but that's okay because it's early.
- [Nick] Yeah.
- That's the answer.
- [Nick] Yeah, I appreciate that.
- And I'm 25, I'm extremely young.
- Right, so at 29, I would do all three.
You know, you've got your
job to pay the bills,
make it practical, you've got
your business on the side,
you've got your passion on the side.
One of those two things prevail,
and that becomes your life.
Where's Samir?
(mumbling)
What the fuck's he doing?
Text him right now, say
I'm looking for him.
Nick D, are you doing anything productive?
(laughing)
What do you got?
- [Man] I love how he's to into it.
- You got something good?
(laughing)
No, I know everything's good.
Where's Soph?
(mumbling)
She hustles, I can't,
I'm like working at two in the morning
and then she's like, I'm like, bloop,
I'm like, she's hustling.
- [Man] She's working in class right now.
- I know.
This should be the show.
(laughing)
Where's Samir?
- [Man] He's texting.
- [Man] He's not gone.
- [Man] He's on a train.
(mumbling)
- He's your boss now, Drock.
I told, listen, you're my new boss.
If I get, listen to me, Samir,
if you get, if I get confident with you,
I will make shit for you on the spot.
People are going crazy
about basketball, huh?
- [Man] Yeah.
- People taking their bracket serious.
Who won the,
tell the truth, because I'm gonna look,
and lying is just a bad idea,
who did not fill out their bracket?
(mumbling)
- [Man] I need a real
gut check (mumbling).
- Everybody's good?
(mumbling)
You made sure, you knew that.
I would have lost my shit with you.
- [Man] That whole table (mumbling)
- Well, 'cause that's
the youngsters there,
they don't know just yet.
- [Man] Tyler came home and--
- Sammy Craig was like
I'm coding over here,
then the algorithm on the fucking,
he's gonna win it.
(mumbling)
You guys outta here?
(clapping)
(mumbling)
Is this for L Squared?
- [Man] L Squared.
(mumbling)
- Let's fucking go Seton Hall,
that's what's fucking up.
This was a big one.
(mumbling)
- Edison, central Jersey or north Jersey?
- [Gary] Central.
- Thank you.
(crowd groans)
- [Gary] Absolutely.
- Wow.
- God, I'm so pissed I
didn't go to JP Stevens.
I love North Hunterdon High School,
but like it's so weird to go through
first grade to eight
grade and then bounce.
Like, that's what happened.
I moved, we moved.
It was tough.
I was just on the cusp of taking
that transition with my crew.
- [Man] That's a hell of a hierarchy.
- And I really did bounce.
I left all my shit in my locker.
(laughing)
I didn't tell anybody.
I didn't tell anybody I was moving.
- [Man] I think there's
actually a shrine there.
- Yeah, I wish.
(laughing)
What the fuck just happened?
Oh, we're good.
I literally bounced,
literally nobody knew.
And this was pre-internet, and pre--
- [Woman] I've been
trying to do (mumbling).
(laughing)
- I get it, I get it.
Have a, see you guys
later, have a good night.
(mellow digital music)